[Music]
michael b jordan and lori harvey are
straight up relationship goals on
valentine's day okay why ain't mad at
that y'all ain't mad on monday the love
bird celebrated cupid's holiday and
shared some sweet intimate moments on
instagram that's the 35 year old actor
gifting his leading lady with flowers
cuddling up alongside her and planting a
big old kiss on her while she sips
champagne
oh and of course there were more
snuggles
it's cool man lori shared all that on
her insta story as well as the romantic
gift she got for michael their initials
painted on a rock inside the call of
duty video game
yeah
listen closely
that's the sound of video game
enthusiasts swooning worldwide super
proud of that and michael he loved it
the black panther star reposted the clip
to his own account writing quote don't
know how you pulled this off but damn
girl this is love adding this was smooth
happy valentine's day thank you baby
girl we really want to raise the bar as
for michael he shared this sweet black
and white clip of lori getting ready
as well as two snaps of the couple
heating things up in the kitchen
of course the two celebrated their one
year anniversary back in november and
when et sat down with the just mercy
star last year he opened up about their
love
what does michael b jordan find very
sexy i think a sense of humor
i think you know the ability to laugh
you know that infectious feeling i think
is i think is really really sexy so a
smile a nice smile and a laugh and a
sense of humor is really sexy to me well
i see why you found who you found then
because she has all of those all those
things absolutely actually very funny a
lot of people don't know that about
she's yeah she's really funny yeah but
does michael have laurie's famous dad
steve harvey's blessing i think i'm a
pretty lovable guy actually the tv
personality opened up about his
daughter's relationship during a stop by
the ellen degeneres show back in january
i'm pulling for him because he's a
really good guy man comes from a good
family you know
i saw him kind of pulling for him but at
the same time i'm just i got my eye on
him you know
i can't whoop him but if he ever turn
around i'm gonna knock his ass out
[Applause]
that boy being in jail man like he comes
in my gym to work out and i'll be going
like whoa
i'm impressed i wasn't going for like
the the ripped boxer look i kind of
wanted to be more you know just beefier
heavier and all that echoes what the
family feud host told et back in
september
this guy is is not a representative
he is genuinely who he who he looks like
he is i mean like it threw me off at
first because he was so kind
you know i figured okay this is the game
right
but it wasn't man this dude was sincere
and he's proven to be a really really
good good guy man i mean look i'm
pulling forward you know i'm pulling for
them me too steve
me too
[Music]
you